my
you
mr portman no
thank you
on this vote the yeas are 50 the nays
are 49 and the joint resolution is
passed
so
you
is
mr president
mr president i
ask unanimous consent
that the senate proceed to executive
session
and consider the following nomination
executive calendar number 476 david a
honey of virginia
to be deputy under secretary of defense
that the nomination
be confirmed
the motion to reconsider be considered
made and laid upon the table with no
intervening
action or debate
that no further motions be in order to
the nomination
that the president be immediately
notified of the senate's action and that
the senate resumes legislative session
is there objection
the senator from missouri mr president i
object and i submit a statement for the
record
objection is heard
mr president
the
the um senator from arizona
mr president the deputy under secretary
of defense for research and engineering
is a critical position that helps lead
and manage our military science and
technology work
this includes work on disruptive cutting
edge technologies like quantum science
hypersonics
and artificial intelligence
maintaining our competitive edge over
china in these areas
has been a focus of the subcommittee
on emerging threats and capabilities
which i chair
and i know that all of us
all of us here understand
how important it is
we worked on a bipartisan basis to
include investments
and policy changes for these priorities
in the ndaa that we are hoping to pass
this week
the deputy undersecretary of defense for
research
and engineering is tasked with carrying
out many of these changes
and yet
the nominee for this post
has yet to be confirmed
dr david a honey is qualified
he brings decades of experience
including as an air force pilot an
intelligence officer
and in leadership roles at darpa the
office of the secretary of defense and
within the intelligence community
reflecting
his qualifications dr honey's nomination
has bipartisan support and was voice
voted out of the senate armed services
committee in october
at a time
when our adversaries are investing
heavily in a in an attempt
to outpace the united states
we need all hands on deck and confirmed
leadership in this post
so i'm very disappointed that we could
not do that today
this is a matter
of national security
i yield back the floor
mr president senator from texas mr
president are we in a quorum call we are
not
thank you mr president
mr president for months now american
families have struggled with the growing
burden
of inflation
new data shows just how bad things have
gotten
last month
consumer prices increased at the fastest
pace
in 40 years
now
i'd like to take a little walk down
memory lane mr president the last time
the american people
endured
price spikes like this ayah the tiger
was one of the top songs on the radio
i'm sure the senator from delaware
remembers that very very very well
the world had yet to be introduced to
the nintendo and mario
and consumers were anxiously awaiting
the release of the first cell phone
which weighed in at a whopping two
pounds
i remember those unwieldy
telephones well
over the last four decades of course a
lot has changed
and i'm not just talking about
technology the attacks of september the
11th
wars in iraq and afghanistan the great
recession
even during the first year of the
pandemic inflation didn't come close
to hitting the heights that it has today
between march 2020 and february 2021 the
inflation rate never topped two percent
there were countless reasons for us to
be optimistic
we had three highly effective vaccines
with shots going into the arms of
millions of people every day
schools were reopening
employees were returning to work and the
american people
began to discover a new semblance of of
normal postcovid
but
the administration ignored all of this
progress because they had another plan
in mind
they seized on what one house democrat
described as a quote tremendous
opportunity to restructure things to fit
their vision
they crafted a nearly two trillion
dollar
piece of legislation that included
their ideological priorities and tried
to brand it as necessary pandemic relief
but we know that only about 10 percent
of that 2 trillion dollar expenditure
actually went to cobit 19. less than 1
percent
went for vaccine
what it did include was backdoor funding
for planned parenthood a blank check for
mismanaged union pensions plans
money for climate justice
it was easy to see through the coven
relief facade
well as our colleagues pushed this bill
forward they ignored warning signs from
leading economists
that this kind of spending chasing
limited goods and services could trigger
inflation larry summers who served as
secretary of treasury during the clinton
the
obama administration even predicted that
this package could and i quote
set off inflationary pressures of a kind
we have not seen
in a generation
our colleagues couldn't be convinced to
change course and look where we are now
as a result
we're experiencing inflation of a kind
that we've not seen in a generation last
month prices jumped a whopping 6.8
percent
from the previous year
marking the sixth consecutive month
in which inflation is topped 5
now
when concerns were raised about this the
federal reserve claimed that this
inflation was transitory in other words
it was a passing moment
but the longer and longer
inflation continues to rise and continue
to be a problem that's looking less and
less transitory and more and more
frightening
the reason it's frightening of course is
because particularly people on fixed
incomes are seeing less and less buying
power for each dollar they spend
it is
some have said a hidden tax
on the american people which describes
its impact
very well
well
month after month the data has now
demonstrated that this is not just
transitory and it isn't just a blip on
the radar of our economy
inflation is running much hotter than
expected and things are not expected to
cool down
anytime soon
as families prepare for the
christmas holiday season they're bracing
their wallets for higher than normal
expenses and one of the biggest hits is
for grocery bills hardly something
optional
breakfast on christmas morning is sure
to cost a lot more than it did just a
year ago
egg prices are up eight percent
bacon costs a whopping 21 percent more
than it did just a year ago
dinner it won't be any cheaper either
prices are up for everything from ham to
salad dressing to pie
cooking that meal will cost you a lot
more too electricity prices are up 6.5
percent
and anyone cooking on a gas range will
shell out 25 more than they did last
year
if you're traveling to see your family
extended family this year you better
start saving for it now
gas prices are up a whopping 58 percent
the largest increase since 1980.
of course this ignores the rising cost
of gifts sitting under the christmas
tree if you can get them
because of broken and delayed supply
chains
so the new cars the washing machines and
sofas countless families have purchased
this year
all of those cost more
you would think that
our democratic colleagues that are
proposing another five trillion dollars
in spending under the so-called bbb
or build back better bill
you would think they would view this as
with caution
and back off of their plans or at least
tap the brakes
for a second round of unnecessary
spending
unfortunately that does not appear to be
the case in fact
the senate majority leader senator
schumer is trying to double down on this
next round of inflationary spending
we know that every trick in the book has
been employed to try to make the
bbb the build back better build back
broke build that back bad build back
bankrupt you call it what you will
but our democratic colleagues have used
every gimmick in the book to make the
price of this
bill
look as small as possible
of course they started with the chairman
of the budget committee senator sanders
wanted to spend six trillion dollars
more
that was paired down to three and a half
trillion now they claim it's only 1.7
trillion
in order to achieve that number they've
gained the tax code to fund part of the
bill while handing out tax breaks to
millionaires and billionaires in relief
for state and local taxes
and they've strategically chosen start
dates sunsets and expiration dates that
make these programs
appear deceptively to cost less
one of our colleagues acknowledged that
this is disingenuous advertising and
even told senator graham the senator
from south carolina that he knew that
this score that they were promoting was
full of gimmicks
of course
that's a lot different than the
president himself who said this bill
will cost zero
now everybody knows
that's not true
but there had been some debate about
what the honest score would be even with
all the gimmicks
but if the temporary provisions were
extended as we all know they would be
there is no such thing as a temporary
government program around here
or as ronald reagan said it's the
closest thing to eternal life is a
temporary government program
this legislation will cost a lot more
than they admit
and we now know how much that will be
senator graham who serves as a ranking
member on the budget committee asked the
congressional budget office to provide a
more accurate cost estimate for this
legislation
others like me and
asked the cbo and the joint tax
committee on taxation to give us an
updated estimate there's been a lot of
requests made to come up with an
accurate truth in advertising
score for this huge bill
last week we got what we asked for we
finally received
the true score for this legislation
and it's a whole lot more than the
american people were told
and much more than they have bargained
for
let's start with the cost provision of
just one part of this bill the expanded
child tax credit
this expansion initially came on the
scene as a temporary measure in the
first partisan spending bill just nine
months ago so this actually builds on
the two trillion dollars our colleagues
passed at the beginning of this year
the very first payments had barely gone
out the door when our friends on the
other side of the aisle been had called
for these temporary provisions to be
made permanent
our colleagues knew that the permanent
expansion would have been far too
expensive so they operated opted for a
temporary
extension
earlier drafts of this bill would have
extended this policy through
2025.
as time went on the price tag was still
too high
so democrats scaled it back to a
one-year extension but still
nothing has changed
calls to make this temporary provision
permanent have not gone away
and i see no indication that our
colleagues will ever be content
to let this extension expire after just
one year
our colleagues on the other side of the
aisle say this provision will cost
taxpayers
185 billion dollars as if that were a
bargain
the latest estimate from the cbo
places the actual cost at roughly 1.6
trillion dollars
you heard that right
our colleagues across the aisle said it
would just cost 185 billion
but the latest estimate from the
congressional budget office
placed the actual cost during the
10-year budget window at roughly 1.6
trillion nine times higher
than what democrats had been telling the
american people
the true cost of this one provision is
nearly
as nearly as high as what our colleagues
said the entire package would cost
then you add in the other higher than
promised expenses the true cost of
payoffs and subsidies subsidies to
organize labor allowing dues to become
tax deductible will cost taxpayers
billions more than advertised
but i'll give them credit
about one thing
they are transparent when it comes to
subsidizing more frivolous lawsuits
against small businesses by giving a
permanent tax cut
to trial trial lawyers
but when you add up all of the not so
temporary provisions the congressional
budget office this bill will cost 4.9
trillion dollars during the first 10
years not
1.75 trillion not zero
but 4.9 trillion dollars
deficits in debt would increase increase
by a staggering 3 trillion dollars
in other words borrowed money that the
next generation or maybe next two
generations will have to repay
which makes president biden's comment
about zero
even more bizarre
when it comes to solving our country's
biggest problems
our colleagues across the aisle have
proven
themselves to be a one-trick pony
whether the american people are
facing a pandemic a sluggish economic
recovery red-hot inflation or any
combination of crises
president biden and our democratic
colleagues here in congress think
trillions of dollars in new spending is
the best path
forward the first round of reckless
spending hurt our economic recovery and
sent the american people on a wild
inflationary ride
our colleagues continue to ignore clear
signals from the economy including
warnings by democratic economists
about the consequences to uncheck
spending
and we're now experiencing the highest
inflation
in a generation
this second round of spending would
usher in more inflation higher deficits
and even a greater financial trouble for
the american people
the american people have clearly
suffered enough
and it's time to simply put the bill
back bankrupt bill out of its misery
mr president i yield the floor
note the absence of quorum
the uh the clerk will call the roll
ms baldwin
[Music]
uh
hello
[Music]
mr president
senator from north dakota
are we in a quorum call yes we are i ask
unanimous consent to just rate the
quorum call
without objection so ordered the
gentleman from north dakota thank you
very much mr president mr president as
we approach the christmas break and the
advent of the new year
i believe it's instructive to take a an
inventory of the year that was
so in honor of the holiday season let's
take stock of the first year of the
reign of biden schumer and pelosi in
fact
in the spirit of the season i'm going to
call this recitation
the 12 biden blunders of christmas
the first blunder that joe biden gave to
us
is a free big government socialist
agenda
otherwise known as the democrats build
back better plan designed to pass with
no support
from or frankly really input from any of
these pesky republicans
time and time again joe biden and his
democratic toy makers have parroted the
claim that their big government
socialist agenda costs zero
zero can you imagine
a piece of legislation designed to give
away trillions of dollars but doesn't
cost anything
but perhaps they have some elf dust that
makes it possible
obviously
this isn't true
analysis by non-government nonpartisan
groups including penn wharton model and
the committee for responsible federal
budget
did an analysis
and uh
concluded that
that the cost was much much higher like
just under five trillion dollars
a recent thorough analysis based on the
history and the traditions of congress
and spending
by the nonpartisan congressional budget
office
agrees
the washington post fact checker even
gave treasury secretary janet yellen two
pinocchios when she repeated the same
bogus claim that this bill would cost
nothing
the second blender joe biden gave to us
is hiding from media reporters and not
taking questions it's kind of
unbelievable to me it's hard to imagine
that the leader of the freest country in
the world in fact the leader of the free
world is afraid to take questions from
the fourth estate or that his staffs
are afraid of what might come out of his
mouth
mr president freedom of the press is
enshrined in the first amendment of our
constitution on purpose
yet on david axelrod's podcast the white
house press secretary jen sachi actually
admitted out loud
quote a lot of times we say
don't take questions
the media in the united states is not
supposed to be the mouthpiece of the
government or its leaders transparency
is essential essential in our
exceptional self-governed system
now i'm not the president of the united
states but reporters who work in the
halls of this temple of liberty and of
course reporters back home in north
dakota know i'm always willing to engage
i don't hide from my votes or
explanations for them i'm not scripted
to the point of resigning my own
thoughts or opinions or even mistakes
and decisions no north dakotans elected
me not my staff
and americans elected joe biden not his
staff not some buffer of bureaucracy
he has the responsibility to be
accessible and the media has the
responsibility to demand it of him
but the slippery slope doesn't end here
another third bunder joe biden gave to
us is the white house deciding what is
quote misinformation
in a news conference jen saki said we're
flagging imagine this now we're this is
the white house spokesperson we're
flagging problematic posts for facebook
that spread disinformation
we're working with doctors and medical
experts who are popular with their
audience with accurate information so
we're helping get trusted content out
there
that's frightening language coming from
a spokesperson for the president it
sounds an awful lot like the united
states government can colluding with the
media to decide what in fact counts as
fact
in fact reading between the lines on
this one it seems the white house is
playing the ultimate arbiter of truth
and if this seems a little orwillian
well
it is
it is
and while it's easy to see why miss sake
might conclude and frankly other
democrats that they in fact control a
state
media
the fact is they don't
give the american people some credit
here they're smarter than being
spoon-fed information from the west
twin through their elephant folk at
facebook
the fourth blunder joe biden gave to us
is raging inflation from pumping
trillions of free dollars into the
economy
we all saw the writing on the wall when
democrats and the biden administration
pushed for two trillion dollars in quote
covered relief in march just three
months
removed from the bipartisan 900 billion
dollar relief bill
this was a total partisan reckless 2
trillion dollars it came at a time when
there was obvious economic recovery
coming out of the pandemic and now
democrats want to spend nearly five
trillion dollars on their build back
broke plan
to put these massive numbers in
perspective
the sum of these two bills just these
two bills
is more than the united states
government spent fighting world war ii
in 2019 dollars the united states spent
4.69 trillion dollars over the course of
just under four years to fight and
defeat nazi germany and the axis powers
liberal and left of center economists
including larry summers and jason furman
sounded warning bells early this year
but democrats forged ahead sending
inflation to levels not seen in nearly
40 years
they continue to insist that inflation
is transitory but americans know better
americans paying more and more for
everything with each passing month no
this is more than transitory inflation
the fifth blunder joe biden's cabinet
gave to us in his homeland security
secretary alejandro mayorka's assessment
of the southern border crisis
remember the hordes of illegal
immigrants camping out under the bridge
in del rio texas
don't worry secretary marcus said as he
lowballed the numbers citing
approximately i think it's about ten
thousand dollars or ten thousand or so
twelve thousand it could be even higher
actually conservative estimates have to
tally upwards of 15 000 people
and while we're talking about the crisis
at the southern border it's important to
note joe biden has made multiple claims
that he's visited the border
but guess what
he hasn't
the washington post fact checker wrote
quote we cannot find evidence that biden
that and one point made a visit to the
southern border in his many decades of
public office
it's as though he thinks if he says it
somehow that makes it true
the problem is lying doesn't make the
lie true
i've been to the border most recently
about six weeks ago and i can tell you
it's bad and i can tell you it's a
crisis
our customs and border patrol agents are
completely overwhelmed i went on a
ride-along and an aerial tour of the rio
grande valley and visited the don
the donna processing facility where
families and unaccompanied minors are
are processed if there's any takeaway
from seeing this firsthand it's this
there's no way to adequately understand
the magnitude of the problem or the
severity of the crisis unless you see it
with your own two eyes
and so i implore the president who has
held elected office nearly uninterrupted
since 1973 please visit the southern
border and acknowledge what is obvious
to everybody else this is a national
crisis
the sixth blunder joe biden gave to us
is a new kind of border wall yeah not
the wall we need to secure the crisis on
the southern border which has seen
record numbers as nearly 2 million
people have attempted to enter the
country illegally under biden's watch
and by the way this is just the number
of illegal immigrants that have been
that have been apprehended by our cbp
heroes
now that's more than twice the popu
population of my home state
but according to secretary mayorkas a
border wall is in the front to quote get
this it's an affront to humanitarian
relief
obviously the ranchers and the innocent
american citizens living and working
near the border don't qualify for this
humanitarian relief
and yet his agency secured and awarded a
contract for nearly half a million
taxpayer dollars to build and install a
fence around joe biden's home in
delaware
what kind of humanitarian relief does
joe biden's beach mansion need mr
president
the seventh blunder joe biden gave to us
is our 450 thousand dollar settlements
for illegal immigrants just for being
illegal
the wall street journal was the first to
report this absurd plan
while north dakota families and
businesses are struggling with inflation
and skyrocketing costs on everything
because of joe biden's spending policy
policies his administration wants to
hand out hundreds of thousands of
dollars to illegal immigrants
in comparison to the 450 000 proposed
payout for illegal border crossers the
united states government government pays
only one hundred thousand dollars to the
families of soldiers killed in service
to our country and people who are
wrongly accused and incarcerated in
federal prison are eligible for just
fifty thousand dollars
that's right a hundred thousand dollars
if you die defending our freedom but
four hundred fifty thousand dollars if
you violate our freedom
now when confronted about this president
biden said this was not going to happen
but he was quickly corrected by his own
white house and the justice department
the negotiations are ongoing so we don't
know what any final number will be
i've i've helped sponsor legislation and
amendments to prevent this policy from
ever being implemented
the last thing we need is another
incentive for people to come to our
country illegally
the eighth blunder joe biden gave to us
is private jet setting climate apologist
john kerry's comments on coal kerry
stated and i quote by 2030 in the united
states we won't have coal we will not
have coal plants
while a state department spokesperson
walked back kerry's statement quote
noting the administration's plans still
would allow coal
it's absurd on its face cutting off coal
would shut down american innovation
kill all the progress we made on carbon
capture technology eliminate good-paying
u.s jobs scrap grid reliability and
increase the cost of energy and
everything that's produced that's
dependent on the energy
like we need more inflation and seed
energy dominance to foreign adversaries
who have a total lack of environmental
concern and standards
canceling coal is merely a transfer of
emissions guilt to other countries with
dirtier energy production than we have
the ninth blunder joe biden gave to us
is moral authority and other gaffes from
energy secretary jennifer granholm
most notably secretary granholm while in
north dakota no less said quote we don't
have much moral authority to call out
china when it comes to energy production
and emissions this is not just wrong
it's embarrassing it's not just an
intellectual mistake it's an
embarrassing gaffe
the stringent environmental and i might
add labor standards of the united states
are far superior to the lack of any of
them in china and i rest my case on the
facts of this situation here
one according to the bbc and several
other agencies but the bbc says china
emits 27
of global emissions and it's a rising
percent because it's a rising number
while the united states is around 10
percent and a declining percent
two according to the epa total u.s
energy related carbon emissions fell by
12
from 2005 to 2018 while the united
states became the number one energy
producer in the world
in contrast global energy related carbon
emissions increased nearly 24
so the united states reduces 12 the
globe increases 24 percent
this is significant by any standard and
certainly qualifies us
to be able to say we have moral
authority over china when it comes to
polluting and greenhouse gas emissions
in north dakota in fact we're performing
ground-breaking research and piloting
innovative demonstration projects
we're in the process of adding carbon
capture technology to facilities like
the milton r young and kolk big power
generation stations
furthermore the united states has
invested more in clean energy research
development and deployment than the next
two countries combined
we're a global leader in climate
mitigation measures for new energy
sources carbon management and efficiency
the radical and backwards energy policy
of this administration ignores american
exceptionalism and the real progress
that we've made as a nation the chinese
communist party russia and other
polluters have shown no real interest in
doing so yet secretary granholm and joe
biden provide cover for them along of
course with john kerry even green
lighting their fossil fuel energy
projects while they kill americas
the tenth blunder joe biden gave to us
is a disastrous withdrawal from
afghanistan there's a lot to unpack here
and nothing about this topic is meant to
be glib or sarcastic this withdrawal was
nothing short of a tragic disaster and
an international embarrassment
we will continue searching for answers
and accountability from the
administration on this but let's focus
on the failed commitments from joe biden
he said his administration would get all
americans and our allies out of the
country ahead of his arbitrary august
31st withdrawal deadline he also said
the us will stay in afghanistan until
all americans who want to leave can do
so
this is obviously not what happened
after the botched withdrawal the
administration listed numbers ranging
from 85 people to 200 or maybe 400
americans not in afghanistan the state
department however believes as many as
14 000 legal permanent u.s residents
remain in afghanistan afghanistan
according to a foreign policy press
report whatever the number mr president
the president went on national
television told the world this
withdrawal was quote an extraordinary
success
mr president can you imagine being one
of the people left behind and seeing
your president on tv calling what he did
an extraordinary success saying that we
got out successfully
it's abundantly clear there are
significant numbers of u.s citizens
residents and important afghan allies
still stranded in the country if in fact
they're still alive at all
the 11th blunder joe biden gave to us is
welcoming stiff competition with china
in october gensake was asked about the
chinese communist party's hypersonic
missile test successfully circumventing
the whole the whole globe which from
reports indicate they're capable of
delivering a nuclear warhead
her response oh we welcome stiff
competition
really
really
why would the white house welcome
military competition from our peer
adversary communist china
as a member of the senate armed services
committee has been a priority to ensure
the u.s military maintains a secure and
effective deterrent a nuclear deterrent
in order to do so we need to modernize
our nuclear triad
america's nuclear triad of missiles
submarines and aircraft are 60 plus
years old in many cases and they're not
the same strong deterrent there are
adversaries to our adversaries that they
once were
it's clear and concerning the chinese
communist party is prioritizing a
nuclear buildup and the white house
seems comfortable with all of this
the 12th blunder joe biden gave to us is
the consistent confusion and alarm in
regards to his own comments about taiwan
in october joe biden told reporters
quote i've spoken with xi jinping about
china or about taiwan we agree we will
abide by the taiwan agreement he said
of course immediately alarm bells rang
out causing confusion and a lot of head
scratching
you have to remember we have a backdrop
of beijing ramping up military pressure
on taiwan and joe biden can't properly
articulate our nation's foreign policy
posture the lack of understanding of
something as critical as china is
dumbfounding
taiwan is a strategic ally and important
trading partner to the united states
especially given the increased risk to
pose us not only to the region but to
the world
if this was an isolated incident it
would be one thing but this isn't the
only time his comments in taiwan had to
be clarified no
in a cnn town hall anderson cooper
interrupted the president to ask if joe
biden was quote saying that the u.s
would come to taiwan's defense if china
attacked
joe biden promptly responded with yes we
have a commitment
the white house resorted once again
to walking back these comments and what
seems to be a recurring occurrence at
1600 pennsylvania avenue and one
washington post article wrote quote most
analysts believe simply that biden
misspoke
misspeaking is a kind way to dismiss the
obvious lack of clear understanding of a
critical foreign policy issue by our
commander-in-chief
if there were to be an attack i'm not
even sure the president would know what
to do if he can't accurately express
what our policy is
mr president i'm not sure i can sum this
up as succinctly as two turtle dozen a
partridge in a pear tree but i can
conclude that joe biden and his left
wing extremist
allies deserve a lump of carbon intense
coal in their white house stockings this
christmas i yield back and note the
absence of i yield back
senator from connecticut
thank you mr president
mr president nine
years ago this morning i was in
bridgeport connecticut i had just done
um an event
with the city of bridgeport i was
meeting
my wife and at the time my two very
young
children
ages four and one
in 2012
at the bridgeport train station we were
going to take
the train down to new york city and i
was going to show my two kids kathy and
i were going to show
our two kids the splendor of new york
city we're going to go see the christmas
tree we're going to go to the ice rink
and as we're waiting for the train to
arrive
i got news that there had been a
shooting at a school in newtown
connecticut newtown's a
beautiful community quintessential small
town close knit
the labor day parade every year attracts
every
civic and community group to it
the pride of the community
and i wondered whether i could still
continue on to this
family trip
or whether i needed to wait to find out
more i figured it was a disgruntled
employee
a few moments passed as i waited for the
train and the news began to come in that
this was much more grim
that there were children shot perhaps
many and i decided that i should get in
a car and
head to sandy hook
there are a lot of days when i wish i
didn't see the things that i saw or hear
the things that i heard
in newtown that day
senator blumenthal who's on the floor
with me
right now
he and i were there and
we were just witnesses we were just
interlopers neither of us
lost a loved one
that day
but it's a
day that i will never ever forget etched
into my brain and we've come here
likely every
december 14th
to memorialize another year having
passed since sandy hook and of course at
some point
you come to a loss for words you can't
figure out what new to say to your
colleagues to try to explain what has
happened to these families to this
community
why
there's such an aching for action
a disbelief that this country
refuses to stand up and do something
about the safety of our kids
because
well newtown caught the nation's
attention for good reason twenty six and
seven year olds
vanishing from the earth in an instant
every single day there are mothers and
fathers who are losing children to gun
violence gun violence that's completely
preventable
a few weeks after newtown i was in a
community center in the north end of
hartford with parents who were furious
that the country was just waking up to
this epidemic of gun violence after
white children were shot in newtown
because they've been happening to their
black children
for decades
and so today
i want to do something very simple for
my colleagues and for the country
i want to just explain to you
what
the grief of these families feels like
what it looks like when you lose
a child whether that child is 6 or 7 or
16 or 17
when you outlive your child when your
child doesn't even make it to adulthood
there is
an all
consuming
grief that is inescapable
one of the emotions that is connected to
this grief that i've learned about is
the tendency to
deny
the reality that has
become your surrounding and it's logical
to momentarily either purposefully or
subconsciously try to
figure out a way out
of this world that you were living in
without your child without your son or
daughter that you had planned to spend
the rest of your life with
and so
i want to talk a little bit about
that emotion today
i live now in the south end of hartford
i live
just two blocks
from
[Music]
the intersection
of south prospect and sheldon street
i think i live there intentionally
because i know this story so well
and when my family and i were looking
for a house in hartford and there was
one available just two blocks from this
intersection
i think there was probably something
intentional about the choice we made
on
and at that intersection
just two months before the sandy hook
shooting shane oliver
a young african-american
20 years old was meeting a couple
acquaintances he was transferring a car
that he had fixed up
to this
other group of individuals that he
knew
in
passing he was there with his girlfriend
and during the exchange of this vehicle
an argument broke out
it started
because of
something untoured
that his
sellers said about his girlfriend it was
essentially an argument over a girl
that turned into a fistfight
that then prompted
luis rodriguez to go back to his car
inside that car was an illegal gun he
walked out of the car with the gun
shane oliver tried to run and he was
shot in the back he died that night
at a hartford hospital
his
mother
for a good deal afterwards
would
wake up in the middle of the night
awaken from a deep sleep
put her clothes on
get into her car
and start driving
she would do this night after night
she'd drive from her home
to the corner of south prospect and
sheldon street where her son died
and when she got there
she would shift her transmission into
park
and she would turn on the high beams
and just wait
for hours
car in park
high beams on
essentially
waiting for her son to come back
it's implausible
shane oliver had died months ago he
wasn't coming back but
his mother consumed by this grief
consumed by this
need to deny what had happened sat there
in her car
around the same time
one parent who both dick and i have
gotten to know very well in sandy hook
came up with
her own trick
she would pretend
that her son who had died that day in
sandy hook wasn't dead in fact
he was just visiting a friend
for the afternoon
she was trying to figure out ways to
just get some housework done to just
tidy up the place to make some phone
calls that she needed to
in order to get her family's business
done and the only way that she could do
that was to imagine
that her son
was at a play date
and that he would be coming home soon
and of course that
dream would vanish and she would once
again
come to grips with the reality that her
son was never ever coming home but that
that need to deny that reality even for
a few hours was what was necessary for
her in order to get through the day
i just tell those two stories because
i want people to understand
how desperate your life becomes
when you lose a child
we lost 26 individuals 20 kids and six
educators nine years ago today
in sandy hook and the families of
all
26 of these individuals the parents the
brothers the sisters the
children
their lives will never ever be the same
new town will never ever be the same
many of these kids lived within a block
or two of each other everyone in newtown
new new
one of these families two of these
families
half of these kids all went to the same
church the funerals that we went to over
and over again
were at the same place
with the same
priest
presiding over
funeral after funeral wake
after wake
and so
sometimes those of us who work in and
around this issue of gun violence get
angry at our colleagues because
how can you listen to stories of this
grief and they happen in every state
and choose
not to act
lastly
i want to do something that i have done
several times on the floor
because
i am running out of ways to express what
happened in sandy hook and
why our inaction is inexcusable
i'm
i'm running out of turns of phrase to do
it myself and so
maybe the words of a parent
will help you understand
why we need to act
so i'm going to read a few excerpts
from
testimony
that our friend neil heslin gave
before the united states senate
just two months after sandy hook
occurred
neil's a complicated guy he's a good
friend
he's had hard times in his life
but his best friend was his son jesse
lewis
and i'll end by reading what he wrote to
the united states senate
nine years ago
on december 14th jesse got up and got
ready for school
he was always excited to go to school i
remember
that day we stopped at misty vale deli
it's funny the things you remember i
remember jesse got the sausage
egg and cheese that he always gets with
some hot chocolate i remember the hug he
gave me when i dropped him off he just
held me
and he rubbed my back i can still feel
that hug
and jesse said it's going to be all
right
i mentioned that his father neal
had a rough life
had hard times like a lot of us
jesse said it's going to be all right
everything's going to be okay dad
looking back on it makes me wonder
what did he know did he have some idea
about what was about to happen
at the time i didn't think much of it i
just thought he was being sweet
but he was always being sweet like that
he was the kind of kid who used to leave
me voice messages where he'd sing me
happy birthday you know my birthday
i'd ask him about it he'd just say i
want you to make
i want to make you feel happy
he had so much wisdom he would know
things and i would have no idea how he
knew but whatever he said he was always
right he'd remember things we'd done and
places we had been that i'd completely
forgotten about i used to think of him
as a tiny adult
other people felt it too teachers would
tell me about his laugh how he made
things at school
more fun just
by being there
jesse had this idea that you never leave
people hurt
if you can help somebody you do it
that's what jesse thought if you can
make somebody feel better you do it
they tell me that's how he died
i guess we still don't know exactly what
happened in that school maybe we'll
never know but what people tell me is
that jesse did something different he
heard the shooting and he didn't run and
hide he started yelling
people disagree about
what he said
but ten kids from my son's class made it
to safety
i hope to god something jesse did that
day helped them survive
what i know is that jesse wasn't shot in
the back
he took two bullets
the first one grazed the side of his
head
but that probably didn't stop him from
yelling
the other hit him in the forehead
both bullets were fired from the front
that means the last thing my son did was
look adam lanza straight in the face
jesse grew up with guns
just like i did i started shooting when
i was eight years old my dad was a vice
president for years at the local gun
club he started taking me shooting when
i was eight he taught me to respect guns
just like i taught jesse jesse had an
interest in guns he had a bb gun i
watched over him like a hawk with that i
taught him gun safety he knew it he
could recite it to you
some guns just don't have a place in the
hands of civilians
the assault weapons we're talking about
today the sole purpose is to put a lot
of lead out into the battlefield quickly
that's what they do that's what they did
at sandy hook elementary
i wish i wasn't here with you today
neil writes
the best day of my life was the day my
son was born the worst day was the day
he died i don't want to relive the day
by talking to you here about it it'd be
easier for me to stay home but i know
that's not what jesse would do
jesse died screaming at a man with a gun
he died yelling at the top of his lungs
so that maybe some of his classmates
could get to safety i'm not real
political half the time i think it
doesn't matter which group of you guys
runs things here no offense
i always thought it wasn't a real good
idea for people to be walking around the
streets with military weapons but
probably i wouldn't have said anything
about it
so the reason i say this isn't about
politics is because what i felt on that
day and what i felt since doesn't have
to do with politics and politics people
like to debate
and say that if we banned the weapon
that adam lanza used we'd he just found
something else but let me tell you when
you're sitting at a firehouse
and it's one in the morning and you're
hoping against hope that your son is
hiding somewhere in the school
you want to make any change that makes
it one bit more likely that you'll see
your boy again
before he died jesse and i used to talk
about maybe coming to washington someday
he wanted to go to the washington
monument when he talked about it last
year jesse asked
if we could come and meet the president
i said earlier that i can be cynical
about politicians but jesse
believed in you
he learned about you
in school
and he believed
in you
i want to believe in you too
right neil
i know you can't give me jesse back
believe me if i thought you could i'd be
asking you for that
but i want to believe that you will
think about what i told you today
i want to believe you'll think about it
and then you'll
do something
about it
whatever you can do to make sure that no
other father has to see
what i've seen
and i were at that firehouse
all day and all night
and i'll never ever forget that when
all the parents had gone home
having told
what happened the first responders had
almost all
left
sitting
in the middle of the firehouse
all by himself
was this one man
it was neil hesslin
i left that firehouse
i can't remember
ten o'clock eleven o'clock at night neil
was the last person i talked to
as he tells you in his testimony he
didn't leave until 1 30.
there was any chance that jesse was
coming back
that he was running around in the woods
neil was going to be sitting there at
that firehouse
it's harder every year
and i have no personal stake in this
i went home that night to both of my
kids
who were
sleeping safely in their beds
what the hell is going on in this
country
that we sit here
and memorialize year after year
since
those 20 kids died
and we don't do anything meaningful
about it
next december will be 10 years
and i'm just going to tell you how hard
it will be for so many of these families
to live through the 10-year
mark of sandy hook
with no action from this body
we have a year to get our act together
here
to make sure that in some small way we
can honor these children with action i
yield the floor
mr president
senator from connecticut mr president uh
this day is
one of profound emotion for both
senator murphy and myself because we
lived through
that day a searing
grief-stricken day that neither of us
will
ever forget nine years ago and at this
moment on that day i
stood before a church full of parents
and members of that
new town community
and what i said then
was
the world is watching
the world is watching
us
and what we will do
and today we remember
not only
what we lost but also
what we still need to do
nine years ago
those 20 beautiful children and sixth
grade educators lost
their lives
and today as we did at saint rose of
lima church
that evening
we remember the lives they lived
their names will be forever engraved in
our hearts
we remember them for bringing bursts of
light and laughter love into our lives
most especially into the lives of their
families
we also remember the heroism
the real heroism
of those educators on that day
six
who
bravely sought to shield their children
literally with their own bodies
sought to
protect their children
running unhesitatingly toward that
danger barricading classroom
drawing on all their reserves of calm
and professionalism
to protect children in their care they
were heroes
and so were the emergency responders
state police
all who came to the firehouse that day i
remember
the
broken
faces
heartbroken
faces
of men who went into
[Music]
the school building
to secure the crime scene
and saw
the bodies of children
that could have been their own
tough
state policemen who'd seen it all
those emergency responders
the ministers
the priests
people of faith who tended
to parents and yes indeed the parents
themselves
heroes
my colleague senator murphy's talked
about jesse's dad neil heslin
jesse's mom scarlett lewis
became a hero
as a champion
of social and emotional learning to try
to prevent the conflict
and the emotional
travail that could lead someone like
adam lanza to do what he did
and i will never forget
at one of those wakes and funerals that
we attended in the days after they
seemed interminable in the cold
and
the deadening light of winter
one mom
whom i approached
and said
when the time is right when you're ready
i think we should do something about gun
violence
and she looked at me
and she said i'm ready now
the ferocity the bravery the strength
and fortitude of those parents in the
days and months afterwards
coming here
as we sought to do something about gun
violence and then sat in the gallery
when by a handful of votes we failed
and the cry of
shame
shame
as one of those parents
shouted to us
they worked bravely and they have
continued
that
work with the kind of unflinching
courage
that it takes every time they tell their
story and every time one of the
surviving families
talks about their children
in the quest to save
others
that is what it's all about that is why
those brave parents heroes
of this story
have continued
for them that december morning began
like every other
they took their children to school kiss
them goodbye
maybe admonish
[Music]
them to be good that day
it was a normal day
until
it wasn't
and then
time stopped
for them and all of us time stopped
and the world changed forever
irreparably irreparably
changed forever for them and for all of
us
and
nine years later
they live with that grief so
far more deeply than any of us
that it almost feels
like
an
incursion
on their privacy to talk about
that day
and the scars of that day for them but
also for the brothers and sisters for
everyone
who suffered a loss that
trauma and grief continued
and
they relive it on this day
there also are heroes in that community
of newtown and sandy hook uh
beautiful
quintessential new england
town with such great spirit as they came
together that evening at the saint rose
of
lima church and in the days and weeks
and years afterward
with
unyielding conviction
and courage
and yet
we know
that they are
so far from alone because
in that time incredibly in the time the
nine years
since
that
day
900 000 more
people
have perished
900 000 more people have died from gun
violence and so many of them children
one-third of american children live in a
home with a gun
and three million children are exposed
to gun violence every year
firearms are the leading cause of death
among american children and teenagers
the leading cause of death
for children younger
than the age of 13.
and so often they occur
at home
outside the front door in the
neighborhood
black children and team
14 more times more likely than white
children
and teens to die by gun homicide
there is a searing inequity and
injustice here
that
radiates outside the boundaries of
sandy hook or newtown it affects every
community
none is immune
none is above
gun violence and because
60 of all deaths by gun violence are
suicide
there are solutions here
like safe storage
and
emergency risk protection orders red
flag statutes that simply
keep guns
safely
stored like ethan's law or
separate guns from people who say
they're going to kill themselves
or others or give evidence that that's
what they're going to do
the good news is we are seeing a new
generation of leaders we are seeing a
political movement not just a moment a
political movement
and a group of
organizations that are mobilizing the
vast majority of the american people who
know
we need to put an end to gun violence
sandy hook promise
new town action alliance
connecticut against gun violence moms
demand action students demand action
giffords brady
march for our
lives in the wake of parkland
march for our lives a new generation
brought together by tragedy
united
regardless of their party regardless of
their other politics
they are together
in demanding action
and with every one of these
mass tragedies
parkland las vegas charleston el paso
orlando
pittsburgh atlanta boulder indianapolis
and now
oxford
michigan
the
scourge of gun violence
has
united these groups
in a way that has never happened before
with the hope that
americans will express themselves not
only
in their neighborhoods and community
meetings but also
at the ballot box to hold us accountable
truly
responsible
for the complicity of congress yes it is
complicity
in that death
and murder that occurs
literally every day more than 100 lives
lost
every day
there are real common sense solutions
here i don't need to describe them in
detail that will be for another day
expanding background checks and closing
loopholes
in that
background check system keeping weapons
of war and ghost guns
off our street funding public health
research
and community violence intervention
program protecting domestic violence
survivors setting standards for safe and
secure storage
implementing those red flag statues and
holding the gun industry and their
nefarious partners accountable
we know
what to do
we know what is
necessary to help stop gun violence
there's no mystery
here
and this movement a political movement
and social movement can achieve it
but
i want to talk
not only about
the grief
suffered by families who have lost
loved ones
but about the impact on the living
who
may not even know about sandy hook
children in schools right now children
who
routinely
do
active shooter drills
diving under their
death
or barricading their doors
in anticipation of a mass
murder
in the place that should be safest
to them
what will this generation
think of
schooling
what will this generation
think of
safety
today in some schools
there was no
school because of the copycat
threats
phoned in to
those
schools what kind of nation
has to shut down schools because of the
threat
of mass murders
not our nation i would hope
not our nation if we
use our power
to make
our nation safer
not our nation if we have the same kind
of courage and guts and grit that those
families
of sandy hook had
we promised then
to honor them with action
and
we should keep in mind
the grace
and bravery
of people like
chris and mike song
who lost their son
a teenager
in a friend's house
to a shooting
that was result
of an unsecured
weapon
unsecured
because
the parents of his friend
failed to put it under lock and key they
made it accessible
kids die like that
every
day every week
and
as our hearts break we should remember
the bravery of chris and michael song
who have crusaded for ethan's law
named after their son
they were here just last week
at a vigil
literally within a stone's throw of the
cap
reciting their story
seeking to inspire us to act
and take that step towards safe storage
taking nobody's gun away
these measures
take no one's going away
they just make it safe
to own a
gun
and to save lives
we have children i have four children
my colleagues on the floor have children
and families we remember those days
when our kids were
six years old
we remember the joy and light they
brought to our lives
and
there is a saying that no parent should
outlive a child
until
we know someone who loses a child but
most especially at that age
the power of that saying
may have less meaning
in 10 years
we
should have done a lot more
if we mark 10 years
without doing more
in 10 years
next year at this time
we should hold ourselves accountable for
doing more
over this next year
we have work to do
and as dark as
december may seem
it is also a season of light
and the heroism of those families of the
first responders of community of sandy
hook
should provide us with the inspiration
we need
to honor
those
brave and wonderful children
to honor them with action
not just words
thank you mr president
mr president
the senator from wyoming thank you mr
president i come to the floor today to
honor an extraordinary public servant
it's my longtime legislative director
bryn stewart
he's going to be leaving the senate
after a 20-year career of working on
behalf of the people of wyoming
he served in this great institution
under two different u.s senators from
wyoming
he and his family have deep roots within
our state and he is a third generation
wyoming guy
brynn was born and raised in sheridan
wyoming
his father clyde was a high school
business teacher who also coached
basketball and the golf team
his mother jerry worked at the sheridan
press our local newspaper
both of his parents encouraged him to
work hard
to always be respectful
and most importantly to be himself
not to be what others expected him to be
well he has exceeded all expectations mr
president i will tell you
family means everything to brin he's the
fifth oldest of seven children
and while it's bryn's career that we're
here to pay tribute to today in terms of
his work in the senate his older sister
kendall was the first steward sibling to
work in the united states senate
she worked for wyoming senator malcolm
wallace
she then came to work
in my own office in sheridan wyoming in
bryn's hometown
it's also important to point out that
brynn's brother dao also worked in the
u.s senate
what a testament to bryn's parents that
so many of their children were committed
to public service
bryn took a very different route to the
u.s senate than his siblings
after graduating from the university of
wyoming with a finance degree
brynn went on to earn his law degree
from the college of law at the
university in 1985.
turns out that brynn wasn't the only
standout from his class that year at the
university of wyoming school of law
my fellow u.s senator from wyoming
cynthia lummus was bryn's classmate in
the law school and the two of them
remain great friends to today
after passing the wyoming state
barbarian has maintained his membership
in the wyoming bar for 36 years
he moved to gillette wyoming and he
started his career there as legal
adviser to the campbell county sheriff
and deputy county attorney now i would
point out that campbell county and
gillette
is the town where mike enzi my former
colleague had been
a representative in the legislature as
well as the mayor
and mike enzi also had graduated ss
brynn from sheridan high school
ten years later bryn became the director
of administrative services for the
campbell county board of commissioners
in that role brynn was able to balance
the budget during a major economic
downturn without laying off any
employees this was not an easy
achievement
now after more than 16 years of serving
the people of campbell county brynn made
the move to washington d.c
he came to dc to work for my predecessor
senator craig thomas as his tax and
trade council
now the person who gets full credit for
convincing brynn to come work for the
u.s senate
wasn't senator thomas it wasn't me
it's my incredible wife bobby brown
barrasso who encouraged bryn to take the
job and move across the country
brynn fondly tells the story of how my
wife bobby who was then the state
director of senator thomas at the time
in 2001
reached out to bryn about the
opportunity that really did change the
course of his life in his career
now she knew that he would be a perfect
fit for the job and we're all very
grateful to bobby in so many ways but
most certainly for recognizing brynn's
talent and talking him into taking a
leap of faith
although it turns out a cross-country
move wouldn't be the biggest shock of
the journey for brandon it's a long way
from wyoming to washington
but he was officially offered the job
the friday before the terrorist attacks
of september 11 2001.
many people would have reconsidered
moving to washington dc
after such
the largest terrorist
attack in our country history
but brynn didn't think twice
in fact it only strengthened his resolve
and his commitment to serve the nation
and the people of wyoming
turns out he would need that resolve
because during his first week in the dc
office
the anthrax attacks occurred against our
nation against our capital and against
the senate office building
anonymous letters laced with deadly
anthrax arrived in congressional offices
and bryn like so many staffers on the
hill were displaced for months
into temporary quarters
despite the chaos and the rocky start
brynn was not deterred and he
immediately jumped into his legislative
role at full speed
for his first two and a half years bryn
served his counsel for senator thomas
he worked on numerous tax and trade
bills
most notably he helped draft and pass
legislation providing critical relief to
drought-stricken livestock producers in
wyoming and across the country
senator thomas was so impressed with
brynn's work that he promoted him to be
his legislative director in 2004.
as you know mr president legislative
directors have a very big job and lots
of responsibility
they guide the entire policy staff in
developing and implementing the
senator's legislative agenda
as a result legislative directors must
be up to speed on all of the issues
brynn recalls one story in particular
from his early days as legislative
director directly on this point
during the 2005 energy bill debate
senator thomas was selected to serve on
the conference committee
a week into the committee meetings
senator thomas then energy legislative
assistant was diagnosed with cancer
never one to back down to a challenge
brynn immediately stepped in
he quickly took over the reins and he
helped senator thomas successfully lead
the fight for wyoming coal and other
important energy resources
brynn recounts this experience as one of
the highlights of his legislative career
always ready to help always ready to act
in 2007 when wyoming and the senate
tragically lost senator craig thomas to
cancer
brynn was central in supporting our
entire staff many of whom are on the
floor today through an extremely
difficult and emotional time
and when i was selected to fill senator
thomas's seat i asked bryn to stay on as
my legislative director
it is a decision that i have never
regretted for more than 14 years
i've been incredibly fortunate to have
his advice and his counsel
we work together on critical issues that
will have a lasting and positive impact
on wyoming for decades to come
now this includes his great work in
helping to pass the craig thomas snake
headwaters legacy act which was signed
into law in 2009
brynn was also instrumental in securing
the return of wyoming's abandoned mine
land funds to our state
which is why i've always referred to him
as our hundred million dollar man
now these are just a few examples of the
work brent is most proud of in his
20-year senate career
friend's dependability and knowledge
made him an indispensable member of my
team
his work ethic and his dedication are
legendary he stays late he works
weekends and he does whatever it takes
to get the job done
we often joke in the office that bryn is
the first one in the lead shop and the
last one to leave
doesn't matter if it's a blizzard
outside or a global pandemic
brynn is infamous for not letting
anything keep him from doing the work in
the senate for the benefit of the people
of wyoming
well i've talked a lot about bryn's
professional accomplishment i also want
to highlight the ways that he continues
to give back to the community and give
back to others
he makes it his mission to live his life
with a purpose
it's one of the reasons his priority is
giving back to the community as much as
he can
one of his biggest passions is
supporting organizations focused on
providing food and shelter to those in
need
he serves a member of the salvation army
board in his local community
he served in organizations that built
homeless shelters operate food pantries
and run low income energy assistance
programs
he's also a member of the northern
wyoming community college advisory board
in gillette
that focuses on providing high quality
post-secondary education to the people
in campbell county and around wyoming
brynn's departure from the senate leaves
very big shoes to fill
and while we're all sad to see him go
we're happy to know he's moving back to
where it all started for him
his hometown shared in wyoming
he'll be closer to family
also be able to spend time camping
hiking and biking through his beloved
bighorn mountains
rin
bobby joins me along with our entire
staff many of whom are here on the floor
the current staff and it is the past
staff the present staff in commending
you on a remarkable career of service
we're grateful that you chose to
dedicate your life
to helping make wyoming in our country a
better place to live and a better place
to work it is with admiration
appreciation and respect
that i wish you every success as you
embark on this new adventure
and we're not just saying that because
today is your birthday you will be truly
missed
thank you mr president i yield the floor
mr president
senator from ohio first i want to offer
my congratulations to brent stewart and
that was a
beautiful
speech about the public service that
he has contributed to wyoming and to
the united states senate
so i thank my colleague from wyoming for
that
i also want to say that over the weekend
i had the opportunity to travel to
kentucky i live in ohio so
kentucky's our neighboring state
and went down to help some of our
neighbors
get back on their feet after these
devastating tornadoes and
it was very emotional
partly obviously seeing people's lives
just be devastated so houses
ruined and
family heirlooms lost and
and unfortunately some loss of life
um through as a tornado hit some of the
residential areas in western kentucky
but also
another emotion which is gratitude for
the people
who came forward as volunteers to help
neighbor helping neighbor
as always happens
when you have one of these natural
disasters
the only silver lining is that people do
come together
and providing
water and food and
um help
getting people uh
out of their their homes through urban
search and rescue teams like ohio task
force one
who went down to kentucky
chainsawing uh
trees down so that people can get their
cars out and and uh
trying to repair some of some of the
damage get their lives back together so
it was a it was
a terrible thing to see the devastation
but also a wonderful thing to see people
coming together to help one another to
get through a tough time
i'm on the floor today
primarily to talk about
the legislation that has been
proposed
by the biden administration and by the
democratic leadership
this is uh
the 11th consecutive week that have come
to the floor to talk about this because
every
uh
week since it was introduced 11 weeks
ago
i wanted to talk about what's actually
in this legislation how it would impact
our communities how it would impact our
economy
so today i'm here to talk a little about
some of the new numbers we have in terms
of inflation and how this would impact
inflation
and
some of the new numbers that just came
out since last week from the
congressional budget office which is a
non-partisan group up here that analyzes
these legislative efforts and what they
are saying about what the cost of this
bill will be
so i think it's worth having this
conversation before
congress uh senate and the house
vote on this massive
tax bill massive spending bill
that could fundamentally change the way
our economy works and
and i think put us in a very difficult
position as it relates to inflation and
the economy and our debt and our deficit
uh democrats want to push this through
on what's called reconciliation which is
a special procedure here in the senate
where instead of getting the normal
super majority of 60 votes
they could do it with only 50 votes and
then have a tiebreaker be
the vice president in in her role as
president of the senate
so
i have concerns about the substance of
the legislation but also in terms of the
process wouldn't it be great if this
could actually go through committees and
the committees could vet some of these
proposals
last week i talked about some of the tax
proposals for instance which i think
have inadvertent impacts
on pensions
defined benefit plans in particular
inadvertent effects on
businesses that aren't going to be able
to write off
expansions of plant and equipment which
we want them to do
maybe some of these things are
inadvertent but it also has a change in
the tax policy where it says that
the state and local tax deduction
would no longer be capped at ten
thousand dollars this is a federal
deduction people were able to pay for
their state local taxes but they'd raise
that to eighty thousand
that cap
the impact that and a couple other
things in the legislation means that
seventy percent of millionaires people
that make over a million dollars in
income a year would get a significant
tax cut under this legislation
whereas if you only make thirty thousand
bucks a year
only thirty percent of those people get
a tax cut
and
and that's in the first year and there's
a second year it goes down to
um
about half that and in the third year it
goes down to 10 and below so
it really is skewed toward
providing tax relief for the wealthy at
a time when
obviously you know we're concerned about
those people
given the economic uncertainty given the
covet issues given the natural disasters
giving the other issues that we face you
would want to help those who need to
help the most that's not what this
legislation does
and again if it had gone through the
process of the committees of
jurisdiction in this case the finance
committee ways and means committee i
don't think we'd be seeing this
all these issues the ones that could
have been ironed out had it not been
jammed through on this reconciliation
process without any committee
consideration
so i'm
upset that
congress is being
thwarted from doing its work
and i think if we had it would be a very
different piece of legislation
this plan is
also going to hurt in my view with
regard to inflation we're looking at the
highest inflation we've had in decades
i think everybody knows that now not
because
they're looking at the numbers which
i'll talk about in a second but because
when they go to the grocery store
they're paying a lot more for hamburger
or for milk
or for bread
or when they go
to fill up their car with gas
they're seeing the prices at the pump i
filled up my pickup truck i took it to
kentucky on this trip i just talked
about
and it was almost 100 bucks to fill it
up
that's a lot for people who are on fixed
income or young people or someone that's
got a commute to work
that really takes takes a bite out of
your budget
but it's that inflation is across our
economy right now and it's tough on
people
the work shortages that we see the
workforce shortages the supply chain
delays
the inflation
all these things are problems in our
economy right now all of them get worse
in my view if we do it the way the
democrats propose because by adding more
fuel to the fire more stimulus spending
in this case trillions of dollars
you're going to stimulate more demand in
the economy
and inflation happens when demand
outstrips supply
you know so you have a lot of demand for
something but you don't have the supply
for it and it raises inflation
and that's exactly
what many of us predict it would have
happened
back in march of this year when congress
did the same thing 1.9 trillion dollars
a lot of it was stimulus spending
and it
people said this is going to cause
inflation and sure enough it did it
wasn't just me and other republicans it
was some democrats as well
so that trend of rising inflation
which has made things so costly and
expensive for so many
people in my home state of ohio
shows no sign of slowing down late last
week
the labor department reported the
consumer price index epa of the cpi rose
by 6.8 percent over the last 12 months
that is the biggest year to year
inflationary increase in 39 years
39 years
and last month the number for inflation
one month alone was point eight percent
so get on your calculator do the math
point eight percent in one month do that
times 12 months you end up with
inflation
of
10
on an annualized basis that's just from
last month if you just extrapolate that
out over the year 10 inflation
for those who lived through inflation in
the late 1970s early 1980s you know what
that does to your economy
so the notion that the
uh biden administration has this is
going to be
temporary or transitory uh that's just
not true and by the way the federal
reserve
has now said that's not true
it's it's going to be here for a while
um
although we're hearing a lot of stories
these days about businesses paying
higher
wages to attract workers
average wages went up by 4.3 percent
last year
so with all the labor shortages and the
increase in wages wages went up 4.3
percent again inflation went up
6.8
in the same 12-month period so this is
why
if you're getting a raise at work you
feel pretty good about it
getting the raise but then you go to the
grocery store or go to the gas pump or
buy some clothes you don't feel so good
about it because your inflation is
higher than your wage gain
so unless your
wage gain is over 6.8 percent over the
last year on average you're losing out
and that's
that's a real problem by the way in 20
as we got into the covid 19
crisis
we had a very different economy in
february of 2020 we had the 19th
straight month of wage gains of 3 or
more and inflation was you know one one
and a half percent so people were
feeling it
which was hey i'm making more money
and it's not being eaten up by inflation
that's not the case now unfortunately
wages aren't keeping pace with these
higher prices and people are finding
their paychecks just don't go as far as
they used to
we can see by
some data that just came out from a
survey of consumer expectations from the
new york fed
that an increasing number of people are
reporting that they're struggling more
financially than they did a year ago
that's from the fed the new york fed
and fewer are expecting their financial
situation to improve by this time next
year
that's not a great feeling
as we approach the holiday season
that's a real concern
the other report we've had since i was
on the floor last week is with regard to
the producer price index we talked about
the consumer price index the producer
price index is about businesses what are
businesses seeing in terms of inflation
on business to business purchases for
instance the new number out this week on
that
is the largest increase year over year
since we started keeping track of this
number which is about
11 years ago 12 years ago
so the producer price index is also
going up
and the consumer price index is already
up
what this means is that that producer
price index number is eventually going
to be reflected in higher consumer costs
right because businesses are going to
pass that along
so this is not a good this is not a good
week because we just got that data
and uh i was very sorry to see it
because what you want to see is that
producer price index going down meaning
that in the future the consumer prices
are going to go down too instead we're
we're seeing a situation where
it's likely that prices are going to
keep going up
again republicans warned of this
when the 1.9 trillion was spent mostly
to stimulate the economy saying this is
going to overheat the economy more
demand less supply partly because of
covid
in other words cobit made it harder to
get to get supply in demand was up
you're going to have inflation sure
enough that's what happened larry
summers
is the former secretary of the treasury
under president obama um
former chair of the national council of
economic advisors
actually who's treasury secretary for
president clinton chair of the national
economic council for president obama
respected
economist uh he too warned of this so
it's not just a partisan issue not
republicans and democrats it's it's the
reality what's happening when you
increase demand much more than supply
can handle you get inflation so it's not
a surprise that it happened
unfortunately his prediction came true
overheated economy demand outstripping
supply we found ourselves in the spiral
of rising prices
that was nine months ago i think it's
fair to say that the inflation
that people said was transitory is going
to stay here for a while that's a real
cause for concern so why are we doing
this
why are we again
spending
trillions of dollars and what is the
cost
uh something that happened since we
talked last week is that the true cost
of the buildback better plan is now
being revealed by this
group on the outside
from university of pennsylvania to the
wharton school by the committee for
responsible federal budget by others but
now
by the congressional budget office
itself so the congressional budget
office is the non-partisan group up here
in congress who tells us what the fiscal
impact is
spending impact taxing impact is
economic impact is of legislation
and you know the number that has been
cited for the cost of this build back
better legislation is 1.7 trillion
dollars over 10 years that's a lot
that would make it to the most expensive
bill ever passed by congress the first
being
the 1.9 trillion we talked about in
march
but it's worse than that
because it turns out that even those
staggeringly high costs we just talked
about 1.7 trillion misses the mark
based on the analysis
that just came out
just as the prices for everyday goods
and services are going up
the estimates we're seeing for the true
cost to build back better are increasing
every analysis we see
these studies have shown us that because
the legislation sunsets programs
that if you actually assume those
programs are not going to be stopped
after let's say with the child tax
credit one year
or two years or three years but you
continue through the life of the
legislation it's gonna be much more
expensive
and so people tell me well rob that's
fine but
the child tax credit as an example only
costs 185 billion dollars only
and i say well actually if you take it
out over time that becomes
uh
the trillions of dollars like 1.6 1.7
trillion dollars
they say well we're just going to do it
for one year
well that's just not what happens here
in congress i mean
the history of this is that once we put
a program like that in place
it continues to live on year after year
let me give you the best example of that
you have probably heard a lot of
democrats saying
over the past few weeks we have to pass
this bill back better legislation by the
end of this year why
because the child tax credit that's
already in law based on the march
legislation is expiring
so there's a tremendous amount of
pressure right they're saying you have
to extend it
well
that makes our case
so you have to extend it this year
that means i assume you have to extend
it next year and the next year and the
next year and the next year
and
anybody who says that they don't want to
extend it on the other side of the aisle
i'd like to hear from them because i
don't think they're going to say that
and so if you assume it's extended
then you have this huge cost the
spending is going to continue to
increase
and the program's not going to sunset
the total cost of the bill goes from 1.7
trillion we talked about to about four
and a half trillion based on the penn
wharton study i talked about
under the congressional budget office
analysis it actually goes even higher
even higher to 4.9 trillion dollars and
when you add interest
on the debt
it goes actually over 5 trillion dollars
so it's difficult to understand these
these numbers we're talking about
because they're so huge
you know
four and a half trillion dollars is 4
500 billion
dollars
we've never spent this kind of money
before i mean
if it's five trillion dollars that's the
size of our budget
or less the whole budget for the entire
country for a year
in one bill
now people say well it's paid for well
it's uh the 1.7 part you could argue is
paid for although we can talk about that
too because some of the things in the
pay fors are not sustainable in my view
including
again the impact on pension funds or the
impact on being able to write off
investments or
the impact of the of the
salt issue
so there's lots of things that need to
be worked out on the
spending
side but also on the revenue side but
let's assume it's 1.7 trillion but
that's not going to cover it because
you've got these expenses like the child
tax credit that will continue
so i'm glad that my colleague senator
lindsey graham who's ranking member of
the budget committee top republican and
senator john cornyn another colleague
asked
the nonpartisan congressional budget
office to do their analysis
because they showed that without the
sunset
the 10-year cost of the child tax credit
goes from 185 billion dollars to 1.6
trillion
they also found that
in line with another study by the
non-partisan joint committee on taxation
that the revenue loss would be 1.6
trillion dollars
either taking us further into debt by
1.6 trillion dollars or requiring new
tax hikes
so
that's just one part of the legislation
it would be the costliest expenditure by
congress in our history but it's just
one part of the legislation the hundreds
of billions in funding
democrats are proposing as an example
for child care under a new approach to
child care which we can also talk about
the substance of that
but it's going to hurt a lot of our
states
the way they're doing it but that'll end
up costing
double the written amount over the next
decade if they remain in place for
example
so all in all the rational budget office
looked at 18 supposedly sunset social
spending programs and found that they
will end up costing the taxpayers nearly
three and a half trillion dollars over
the next decade when they get extended
if they do
and again the history around here is
that they would
so
you know it's just the price tag goes up
and up and up
when you add that spending to another
program
and build back better cbo says the total
spending the legislation goes again to
4.9
trillion dollars i have 4.9 trillion
dollars is bigger than the economy of
any country in the world with the
exception of the u.s china and japan
again these numbers are just
astronomical
but think about that it's bigger than
the entire economy the entire gdp of any
country in the world except for the
three of us united states china and
japan
we're seeing record debts and record
deficits right now as you know
the congressional budget office says
that
the american people can expect build
back better if the sunsets don't hold to
add another three trillion dollars to
the federal deficit
so as we continue to debate this in
congress which way should we go we just
ought to know these numbers we had to
analyze them
and again if people on the other side of
the aisle are going to say we don't want
to have the child tax credit be extended
we need to we need to know that
but my sense is just as they want to
extend it right now they want to extend
it next year and the next year in the
next year
so
is this the right time to do that
is this the right time to add that kind
of stimulus to an economy that already
is over stimulated where you got more
demand chasing not enough supply do you
want to add more to the demand side
that's what's going to happen if we pass
this
so i hope that we will not make that
mistake i hope that
we will slow down
and look at these numbers and analyze
where we are in terms of our spending
we just extended the debt limit
no republican voted for it but all the
democrats voted for it and that's all
they needed to be able to extend the
debt limit because it was under a
special 50 vote margin
that debt limit was just extended for
basically one year so after the
elections
next year
two and a half trillion dollars
more debt we had to make room for two
and a half trillion dollars more debt
in one year
it's clear
that a lot of americans are nervous
about this when you look at
polling data it says that but just
talking to people
over the weekend i was also in southeast
ohio
part of our state
it's very rural a lot of people are are
hurting in terms of the economy because
they don't have access to broadband and
so on so
um
we're talking about
how they feel about the economy and
there's a lot of nervousness
they feel the surging inflation
they're paying more for everything
and
you know
common sense people are saying let's
just slow down and think about this
they may end up thinking at the end of
the day they're they're for some of this
but they don't want to move forward
precipitously and make a mistake and and
have this add more inflation and more
problems for our debt and deficit for
our kids and grandkids
they're saying let's do the right thing
for the country and put the brakes on
this
and if we do put the brakes on this
unprecedented spending and taxing
it will help us to avoid some of these
economic challenges that we're otherwise
going to be facing if we go ahead with
it it's going to make these economic
challenges like inflation
even worse
so my hope is that
we'll put the brakes on
and these economic challenges
will not worsen
and instead we can get the country back
on the right track
i yield the floor
[Music]
great
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
the senator from washington
we are not in a quorum call
i ask unanimous consent that the senate
proceed to executive session to consider
the following nominations in block
calendar number 402
587 606 that the senate vote on the
nominations on block without intervening
action or debate the motion to
reconsider be considered made and laid
upon the table with no intervening
action or debate that any statements
related to the nominations be printed in
the record and the president being
immediately notified of the sentence
actions
is there objection
without objection
the question occurs on the nominations
on block
all those in favor say aye
all opposed no the eyes appear to have
it the eyes do have it
the nominations are confirmed on block
madam president i ask unanimous consent
that the senate consider the following
nominations on block calendar number 497
597 and 598 that the senate vote on the
nominations on block without intervening
action or debate the motions to
reconsider be considered made and laid
upon the table with no intervening
action or debate and that any statement
related to the nominations be printed in
the record of the president being
immediately notified of the senate's
actions
is there objection
without objection
the question occurs on the nominations
on block
all those in favor say aye aye
all opposed no the eyes appear to have
it the eyes do have it
the nominations are confirmed on block
madam president i ask unanimous consent
the senate consider the following
nominations calendar number 600
601 602 603 604 and all nominations on
the secretary's desk in the air force
army marine corps
navy and space force that the
nominations be confirmed to unblock the
nominations to be considered made and
laid upon the table with no intervening
action or debate that no further
nominate further motions
be made in order
to any of the nominations that the
president be immediately notified of the
senate's actions and then senate then
resume legislative session
is there objection
without objection
mr president i ask unanimous consent
that the senate proceed to the immediate
consideration of h.r 5746
which we received from the house
the clerk will report hr 5746 an act to
amend title 51 united states code to
extend the authority of the national
aeronautics and space administration to
enter into leases of non-access property
of the administration
without objection the senate will
proceed
i ask unanimous consent that the
cantwell amendment which is at the desk
be agreed to
the bill as amended be considered as
read a third time and passed and that
the
promotions to be reconsidered
be considered made and laid upon the
table without objection
i ask unanimous consent that the senate
proceed to the immediate consideration
of calendar number 127 s 1543
the clerk will report
number 127 s 1543 a bill to amend the
public health service act and so forth
i ask that the committee uh reported
substitute be agreed to the bill as
amended be considered read a third time
without objection
i know of no further debate
is there further debate
hearing none
all those in favor say aye aye
all opposed no
the eyes appear to have it the eyes do
have it
the bill is passed i asked uh that the
motions to reconsider be considered made
and laid on the table with no
intervening action or debate
without objection i ask you know some
consent that the senate proceed to the
immediate consideration of calendar 177
s 1097.
the clerk will report
counter number 177 s 1097 a bill to
establish a federal rotational cyber
workforce program for the federal cyber
workforce
without objection the senate will
proceed
i ask unanimous consent that the bill be
considered red a third time and passed
and that the motion to reconsider be
considered made and laid upon the table
without objection
i ask you now consent that the senate
proceed to consideration of s res 479
submitted earlier today
the clerk will report
esres 479 supporting the goals and
ideals of american diabetes month
without objection the senate will
proceed i ask unanimous consent that the
resolution be agreed to the preamble be
agreed to and that the motion to
reconsider be considered made and laid
upon the table with no intervening
action or debate without objection
i ask unanimous consent that when the
senate complete its business today it
adjourn until 10 a.m wednesday december
15th that the following the prayer and
pledge the morning hour be deemed
expired the journal of proceedings be
approved to date the time of the two
leaders be reserved for their use later
in the day and morning business be
closed that upon the conclusion of
morning business resume consideration of
the house message to a company s-1605
further that at 11 30 the motion to
concur with the amendment for
48.80 be withdrawn and the senate vote
on the motion to concur
and that the following disposition of
the house
message the senate proceed to executive
session to resume consideration of the
sung nomination and vote on confirmation
of the nomination further at 2 15 pm the
senate vote on confirmation of the
elliott nomination
and finally if any of the nominations
are confirmed the motions to reconsider
be considered made and laid upon the
table with no intervening action or
debate and the president president be
immediately notified of the senate's
action
without objection
if there is no further business to come
before the senate i ask that it stand
adjourned under the previous order
the senate stands adjourned
until 10 am tomorrow
you